what's happening right now
Chloe has found the right spots where to
put the electrodes so we're gonna put
two electrodes on the occipital part of
the brain so the back of the head then
we're gonna have a couple of electrodes
in the central part and a couple of
electrodes on prefrontal areas these two
electrodes are basically measuring her
frowning muscles if she has a nightmare
maybe she frowns we'll see some activity
next step we're going to connect her to
the computer only the electrodes they
capture an averaged activity of hundreds
of thousands of neurons and the way we
today in conceptualized sleep stages is
by the predominant frequency of neurons
firing now you can go to bed however
we'll be waking you up a few times for a
dream collection at sleep onset sweet
dreams
I studied dreams because I dream a lot
and investigating those phenomena helps
me understand my own experiences better
in certain ways I also study dreams
because I'm fortunate to be working in a
dream a nightmare laboratory in our lab
is is pretty special in the sense that
there are a lot of sleep labs around the
world but it's pretty rare to have a lab
specifically dedicated to scientific
study of dreaming so in dream research
our main difficulty is that we have to
rely on people's first-person reports
and people vary greatly in their
introspective capacity and in the way
they used to tune into the world in the
way they would describe visual auditory
olfactory kinesthetic sensations etc so
what we want to know is is it possible
to find an expert group of dreamers the
personal meditation is a kind of
meditation where people typically start
with just mindfulness of the breathing
and attending to a tuning to their
sensations without judging and then
slowly progress to scanning their whole
body we're hoping that we pass the
meditators because they used to paying
attention to those things will actually
describe better the kind of bodily
changes that they will undergo during
sleep and in dreaming
these are sleep key complexes in sleep
spindles in just having more and more
slow waves so she's actually falling
deeper asleep dreaming can be so intense
and so vivid that it will affect how you
live your life some people have
nightmares that make their waking life
miserable and the effect is carried over
moving
another offshoot of my study takes part
at the topological Media Lab where we
create immersive audio-visual
environments we want to probe more into
the depth of dream experience in an
interactive interpersonal way right now
we are at a very interesting historical
moment when meditation studies and dream
studies are really exploding there is a
real rise of interest in subjective data
in complementing subjective data with
third-person data and then we would also
need overarching humanities to help us
bring those two together
mixing neurosciences with humanities
with philosophy with media arts that
allows for very unusual collaborations
and so for very unusual insights into
the human mind REM sleep is a sleep
stage when we're most likely to have
vivid intense immersive dream
experiences so at that point we would
wake them up and would expect them to
give us the dream report
hey Michelle would you tell us your
dream okay at the beginning of the dream
I was in bed here and I was trying to
fall asleep and a little gray cat came
in onto the bed but actually it was Lisa
and Lisa was telling me it was time to
get up
and then I I walked out into the into
the the lab room actually following
leaves of the cat and at some point
though I became aware that I was
dreaming and Lisa had little potato
chips sprayed out all over the room so I
think that's when I realized I was
dreaming I know there were all sorts of
like machines in the room it wasn't just
the computers like it is now there were
other machines that were all like
working like there seemed to be like a
conveyor belt going around the room I
remember flying for a minute moving my
legs up and down like a dolphin and then
I was in a new scene I was in a tree and
I was in like a group of women and we
were feeling left out because they were
all talking and I wasn't really included
in the conversation yeah I guess that's
all I can remember
thank you that's it that's okay yeah
this is really a pilot study this is the
first time we've ever done anything like
that so our future studies will be
informed by our successes and our
mistakes we'll see what the future holds
but I would really like to keep
exploring the mind from all those
different perspectives
Ripple's
starting from where you're poking the
pond set out and they spread over the
surface of the pond so on science
picture of space-time is also is similar
if there's a black hole that sits around
in its space and has nothing bright
around it or no other matter that's
falling into it that can go
we can't know about it we can't learn
much about it whereas if we could study
the gravitational waves from that black
hole we could reconstruct almost
everything about it